all right so the 83rd Annual Academy
Awards just aired but for my people my
fellow film fans we want to know who won
at the Academy Awards but didn't want to
sit through about 4 hours of programming
this videos for you I'd give you the
winners of the 83rd Annual Academy
Awards in less than one minute starting
now and it goes art direction Alice in
Wonderland cinematography inception
supporting actress Melissa Leo animated
short the lost thing Animated Feature
Toy Story 3 adapted screenplay the
social-network original screenplay
King's Speech foreign film in a better
world that one got by me supporting
actor Christian Bale in the fighter even
made fun of his freakout rant that was
awesome Original Score Trent Reznor the
social network best sound mixing
inception best sound editing inception
best make up the Academy Award winning
movie the Wolf Man costume design Alice
in Wonderland documentary short
strangers no more live action short film
god of love some funny auto-tune [ __ ]
that was badass documentary feature the
inside job and then Jude Law tells Iron
Man one of the funniest things I've ever
heard in my life visual effects
inception editing the social network
Best Original Song Randy Newman we
belong together from Toy Story 3 best
director Tom Hooper for The King's
Speech best actress Natalie Portman for
the Black Swan best actor Colin Firth
for The King's Speech and yes it would
make sense the best director and best
actor make Best Picture and the Best
Picture is the King's Speech done so
that's it there you go four hours of
programming unnecessary but James Franco
was awesome and Anne Hathaway she was
odd so there is that but if you want to
check out a fun award show check out the
you reviewers award show here on YouTube
just throwing that out there so if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
well am I dressed up because it's the
Oscars makes me feel like I'm there and
because I can